alors il est un sujet que vous avez
traité dans la télévision japonaise
c'est l'exposition picasso une
exposition c'est plus exactement le
l'inauguration du musée picasso est
depuis une semaine ce musée ne désemplit
pas plus de cinq cents peintures et
sculptures trois mille dessins et
estampes véronique bonnet est allé
regarder de plus près les raisons de ce
succès
l'hôtel salé dans le marais ainsi
dénommée parce que son constructeur et
premier propriétaire pierre aubert
percepteur sous mazars a été chargée de
récolter l'impôt sur le sel entraîné
dans la chute de fouquet est ruiné il
habite à ce magnifique hôtel que trois
ans dès lors et pendant trois siècles
celui-ci se promena de main en main
avant de devenir la maison le musée de
pablo picasso
il aura fallu dix ans depuis la première
à pulsions de michel guy en 75 pour
restaurer et aménager ce musée dans
toutes les structures d'origine ont été
conservés picasso l'artiste le plus
novateur de son époque n'émet que les
demeures anciennes et cet endroit du cos
pont bien avec son ampleur et sa
magnificence mais aussi avec ses recoins
propice aux amoncellements dont il
aimait s'entourer
parent parfait parfait dans votre
peinture va bien de toute façon un peu
partout et surtout dans un cas pareil
quel est votre période préférée si vous
donnez les unes le cubiste et la période
des années vingt deux les transforme les
femmes sur la plage sas j'adorais ça
enfin tout mais peut-être aussi je
préfère peut-être ses grands tableaux
les trois femmes à la fontaine cesse on
est à la maison parce que les américains
en ont beaucoup on en avait secret bien
de pouvoir les voir sur je parlais en
amérique
toutes les périodes sont présentes dans
cette dation des picasso du picasso plus
de 500 oeuvres peintures sculptures
bas-reliefs des céramiques les années de
jeunesse la période bleue avec cet
autoportrait de 1901 la période rose qui
annonce les demoiselles d'avignon cd
époque encore très classiques sont
d'ailleurs les favorites du grand public
le cubisme avec des toits qui n'ont
jamais quitté l'atelier du peintre puis
le gros morceau peut être la moitié de
la donation qui couvre la guerre et
l'après guerre
est ce qui est très intéressant c'est la
situation de la collection personnelle
de picasso d'oeuvre de ses amis ou de
houe de peintres qu'il aime beaucoup à
l'intérieur de son de son prof sa propre
démarche
et ça je trouve que tous les musées
devraient s'inspirer de ce type de
démonstration en or de ça je vous dis
qu'on est extrêmement ému et par le
contenu est pas le contenant de ce musée
qui qui était étonnant l'accrochage de
dominique bozo le conservateur l
architecture de roland simonet qui mêle
les objets aux oeuvres ont su préserver
le caractère à la fois intime et
grandiose de ce lieu un lieu qui depuis
300 ans attendait son main